I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her I did not
[Music]
he walks the battle for Endor man I'm so
glad I decided to watch every single
Star Wars film and review all of them
because I got to watch these two
masterpieces this film picks up with
young Sindel from the previous film her
family still stranded on Endor but this
time around her dad has been replaced
with a different actor that's right
that's the asshole from die hard and due
to spending a lot of time with Sindel
wicked can now speak English these two
Ewok films take place before Return of
the Jedi they were at some point in time
considered canon a few countries
actually showed them in movie theaters
despite the fact that in the United
States they were both television movies
so it doesn't really make sense that
wicked would know how to speak English
before he meets Leia in Return of the
Jedi because he would have understood
exactly what she was saying
and he would have said more than in gap
he would have been like hi I'm wicked
and Leia would have been like oh shit
hi I'm Leia and it would have been like
a you know like a really cool scene so
the plot does start a lot faster with
this one some Planet of the Apes looking
dude and a woman who looks like a
rejected Power Rangers villain attacks
the family and I'll give the battle for
Endor this it starts faster than the
other one the plot is introduced and you
actually feel like something's happening
there's a lot more action than caravan
of courage and things are actually
taking place and you're like okay this
feels like kind of a movie and pretty
much right off the bat sin Dells entire
family gets murdered brutally by these
Planet of the Apes looking guys her
brother her mom and she's left with her
dad the asshole from die hard and their
reaction to their deaths isn't quite
what you'd expect
mommy they're dead it's just kind of
like hey our family's dead you know what
are we gonna do now
whatever Oh dad's dead too well at least
I have wicked now so wicked and sindell
flee into the mountains and inside a
cave wicked finds bones and rocks and a
small piece of cloth and somehow with
all of this he's able to build a fully
functioning paraglider but then this
thing attacks them and starts a chase
with a paraglider we now for a lot of
people Jar Jar Binks is one of the most
annoying characters and all of the Star
Wars universe myself included but in
this film were greeted with the
appearance of the most derpy little
gremlin creature that I have ever seen
this thing is going to haunt my dreams
for the rest of my life in the future
when I have children I will show them
this thing's face to terrify them into
doing their chores and their homework
every time that thing was on screen I
just wanted to reach into the screen and
rip it apart all that being said the
cinematic presence of one Wilford
Brimley definitely improves the
proceedings holy shit Wilford Brimley's
in this movie I had no idea that he was
hit I was watching I was like Wilford
Brimley what I'm Wilford Brimley and I'd
like to talk to you for a few minutes
about diabeetus and despite the presence
of Wilford Brimley they have to
continuously remind us this is a movie
made for kids because look wicked set
his butt on fire this film also contains
the most terrifying shot of wicked I
have ever seen he looks like a legit
creeper like he would show up on the end
or sex offenders list for sure
next Sindel has a legitimate nightmare
about being murdered so that's
interesting it's almost like they were
trying to make one of those dark
children movie moments that Tim Burton
did so well in pee-wee Herman's big
adventure stuff that like your as a kid
you're watching it they're like oh my
god they're just scary part now what are
the most broken things about this movie
is that these Planet of the Apes guys
I'm just gonna keep calling them that I
know what they're called I don't care
I'm calling a Planet of the Apes guys
they enslaved the entire II walk village
they're trying to get this power source
resuscitated that's their goal they want
to get this battery back to work I guess
and while all the Ewoks are enslaved
wicked is with Sindel and Wilford
Brimley and that derpy gremlin making
pies like for all wicked knows all of
his family and friends they're all being
tortured and murdered he's just making
pies it's probably because and I don't
blame him for this he just really wanted
to have apple pie with Wilford Brimley
and I've eaten ice cream an apple pie
and I've done things I shouldn't do now
they spend pretty much the entire second
act wandering around in the woods and
singing
[Music]
in the sky shining hot so there's a
witch of sorts that can turn into a bird
she leads Sindel to this Planet of the
Apes place and Wilford Brimley has to go
full commando to rescue her
[Music]
and he gets to the prison it helps all
the Ewoks escape leading to one of my
favorite shots in the entire film
the Ewoks flee into the woods and this
stop-motion army follows them so simple
you and a couple of your little friends
that are come with me okay you're in
charge of the other then Brimley puts
wicked in charge of everyone
only because wicked is the only one he
knows by name for all he knows he could
be the dumbest II walk in the entire
village and he just makes them the
leader of everyone eat your oatmeal
wicket if you're on a low-fat
low-cholesterol diet add Quaker Oatmeal
to it how it every day if you can you
see oats has this special kind of fiber
and what it does well it helps lower
your cholesterol so the battle for Endor
finally starts and Ewoks are swinging
everywhere and the derpy thing is
running and I guess stuff is happening
and so you can actually look at this and
not feel like medically inducing sleep
Brimley gets behind a gun turret and I
think they just told him to improv stuff
because he just starts saying shit and
it doesn't really make any sense
wicked gets strung up in a trap because
as I said he should not be the leader of
the Ewoks and everyone has to then
rescue him and they didn't even bother
making this bad guys mouth animatronic
his lips don't even move a box I don't
like a box oh gosh suck I'm the name bad
guy from bad of her and are I not like a
LOX all that being said this movie
definitely taught me that I never knew I
wanted a sword fight sequence with
Wilford Brimley but I'm glad that I got
it but my favorite part of the movie is
when that stupid little derpy gremlin
gets thrown
[Music]
oh I love that so much it's such a great
part in fact it's funny my favorite
parts from both of these movies caravan
of courage and now battle friend are the
first one was when the one a walk got
crushed by falling rocks
this one's when that thing gets thrown
into a fucking tree
but finally wicked proves me wrong when
he throws something at the bad guy and
it turns him into stone and I can tell
you that I definitely thought the story
was very clear on what the hell just
happened there wasn't a single part of
that out of left field that all made
perfect sense so they fixed their ship
and they can leave and the movie ends
and everyone celebrates yay I did it
I've reviewed every single Star Wars
movie it feels so good oh my god Oh last
Jedi is coming out very soon and that's
one I haven't reviewed but what I'm
actually really looking forward to
seeing guys thank you so much as always
for watching and if you liked this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]